[Applause]
there are
a bunch of islands that the united
states owns at the very edge of this map
deep into the pacific like out here and
they all say like a little
u.s next to them their teeny tiny island
where no one lives and they're just in
the middle of the pacific
so far away from the actual united
states why do we own all these weird
islands
what happened well it has to do with
farming and bird poop
[Music]
back in the old days farming looked like
this
[Music]
basically just small groups of people
usually a few families that would grow
food for their community and that was
about it
but soon the world started to change and
started to look a lot less
like this and a lot more like this
people started moving into the city and
working in factories
mass producing commodities and items
that would be shipped
all around the world and suddenly
farmers had an incentive
and a duty to make more food to ship it
to these non-farm workers who are now
living in cities
farms started specializing in one crop
like
corn or wheat and they were able to sell
their crops not only
to their local markets but to markets
all around the world but there's a
problem here
when you're a farmer and you're
producing the same crop year after year
your soil starts to lose its nutrients
it doesn't have time to regenerate
and it eventually becomes completely
exhausted making it
impossible for you to produce in
abundance
and if you can't make food in abundance
then you can't feed these ever-growing
cities of people who are working in
factories and then the global economy
starts to break down and the whole thing
stops for a moment there in the 1800s it
was looking like
earth would not be able to sustain a
population
over like two and a half billion people
because there wasn't
enough nutrients in the soil to keep up
with the demand for food
but luckily there was a solution to this
soil nutrients problem
and that solution looked like this
[Music]
animal waste from any animal is packed
with the nutrients that the soil needs
to rejuvenate itself to grow more crops
year after year
another term for this is fertilizer and
so now we're talking about farms
and industrialization and fertilizer and
you're probably thinking
this is a boring story but these simple
facts led the united states to
expand well beyond the borders that we
think of the united states today
to colonize far-flung islands in the
pacific in the caribbean
all in search of one special commodity
bird [ __ ]
[Music]
so it's the mid-1800s and like i said
these farmers are growing a ton of a
single crop
sending it mainly to cities to be
consumed now before
all of this urbanization when people
would eat this food
the waste that they would produce would
be captured and brought back onto the
field
which would help rejuvenate the
nutrients in the field and allow them to
continue
to grow in this sort of sustainable
cycle but now
all of that human waste was being piped
into sewage systems
and then sent out to rivers and to the
ocean
completely lost one estimate said that
every year 50 million dollars worth of
valuable fertilizer
was just wasted away through the sewer
system
and this is where the bird [ __ ] comes in
if you go down to peru and look right
off the coast you're gonna see
a few islands these are a little more
than just
some rocks in the middle of the ocean
that were totally uninhabited
well i guess they were inhabited just
not by humans but
by birds these birds spend their day
eating fish from the ocean around the
rocks inevitably dropping their waste
pair this with the fact that these rocks
don't get a lot of rain so instead this
bird dung just sits there
day after day year after year baking in
the sun
and eventually it becomes like rock hard
you can imagine that after
thousands of years of this process you
start to get some pretty
thick layers of bird [ __ ] these deposits
would get
up to 60 meters that's like the size of
this random building in argentina that i
found on the internet the building's not
important
the height is this calcified bird poop
is called
guano and it contains exactly
what the farmers in the united states
needed to continue
with the demand for more and more food
in the cities
because again bird and animal waste is
full of
chemical properties like nitrogen that
are vital
for regenerating soil meaning they're
good fertilizer
once this guano was discovered there was
a race
for everyone around the world to get
their hands on it
soon in the united states guano became
this like mythical
magical substance there's all these tall
tales that pop up where like
this dad leaves his kid in the shed
where the guano is contained
and he opens the shed an hour later and
the kid is now a full-grown man with
facial hair
or the farmer who sprinkles guano on his
cucumbers
and the vines of the cucumbers pop up
and start to like
attack the man i mean it's just this is
crazy it's obviously not
fact-based or true but it gave a sense
that there was this craze that guano was
going to be
the savior of all of the farmers issues
in the united states
so inevitably an economy and a trade
around guano emerged
and as always at this time the british
got there first
so there was a british firm that had a
monopoly over all the guano trade from
these islands in peru
which was sort of the best known place
for guano at the time so with this one
british firm controlling
the whole guano trade and demand surging
the prices skyrocketed making it way
more expensive for american farmers to
get their hands on this
amazing stuff so who steps in to solve
this issue
the president of the united states in
his first state of the union address
president fillmore gets up
and talks about guano he says that quote
peruvian guano has become so desirable
an article
that he felt it quote the duty of the
government to secure it
at a good price for american farmers
this is
crazy to me can you imagine the
president of the united states
getting up to address the nation and
making it a national priority to go to
some
far-flung place to secure some natural
resource that is really important for
economic growth
on my orders coalition forces have begun
striking selected targets of military
importance
to undermine saddam hussein's ability to
wage war
yeah i mean it's not that weird i guess
um
so yeah this is becoming a geopolitical
issue the president is involved
they want all the guano president
fillmore says quote
nothing will be omitted on my part in
the effort to secure this magical
life-giving bird [ __ ] okay actually he
didn't
say that last part that the quotation
should have ended like
like up here i just sort of paraphrased
the rest
the point is president fillmore was
serious about this issue he was going to
get his guano
at any cost so he did what you do when
you're a
rising superpower and he promised to
send in warships to these peruvian
islands if he had to
in order to secure guano at a good price
even though
peru rightfully had sovereignty over
these islands
and yet here's a president sending in
warships
in order to secure the resource again
kind of sounds familiar america is
addicted to oil
but american lawmakers in congress had
another
answer to this problem which would allow
americans to get
their own guano islands the proposed law
said that any american citizen not a
government official or
a military personnel could go out on
their boat
anywhere in the ocean and if they
stumble upon one of these rocks that's
covered in
calcified bird poop they could claim it
not just for themselves but for the
country of the united states
no treaties no negotiations no official
declaration
no government involvement even just
american citizens out on their boats
looking for bird poop islands
some lawmakers at the time were
understandably uneasy with this law
now remember that the u.s was expanding
a lot at this time
remember that video i made about mexico
and how they're sort of taking over
texas and california and that whole area
yeah that's happening around this time
but the u.s hadn't moved beyond this
land mass
this contiguous shape that we think of
when we think of the united states
yeah we had moved west but we hadn't
gone for
far-flung colonies far into the pacific
ocean
and secondly the lawmakers are like
since when do we let
just like random american citizens go
out and like help us
colonize islands anywhere in the world
this would set a precedent that
these lawmakers were worried would have
way bigger consequences
than just like letting people go get
fertilizer for their farms
the sponsor of this bill who was trying
to get it through congress
came out and said listen guys you're
overreacting this isn't like legit
imperialism we're not like going out and
like taking over whole countries like
the british or the french we're doing
carving up continents no no no we're
just going to these rocks to get some
fertilizer for our farms it's harmless
and this was apparently enough to
convince the critics
and this law passes the guano islands
act of 1856
where literally any american can go help
expand the united states by claiming
guano islands
and mining this stuff and bringing it
back to the united states
and so now a giant blitz of guano
exploration begins by american citizens
sort of like the gold rush but you know
for for bird
soon these claims start rolling into the
u.s government
random guy x from nebraska sailed to a
random island
in the pacific planted an american flag
and now it belongs to the united states
of america all in all by the end there
were 94 separate islands
mainly in the pacific and the caribbean
the guano was
chipped away harvested put on ships
brought back to the united states
and farmers thrived
but you know who didn't thrive the
people who had to mine this stuff
i mean you can imagine being the person
who has to go onto these islands
where you have thousands and thousands
of years worth of layers
of bird droppings to drill and cut that
away
and to bring it onto a ship to be
shipped back to united states it's just
like
excruciating to think about this was a
pretty horrendous job and it came with
all sorts of
side effects like lung issues or running
out of food because you're not on an
island that grows food you're on a
literal like
rock and so the food would go bad in
these ships and the people would be like
stranded at sea
unsurprisingly these guano barons
would trick people into coming with them
on these expeditions in the case of the
pacific they would often target
hawaiians to recruit for these jobs
and in the case of the caribbean they
would often target black americans
recently freed from slavery
to come work on these guano ships as
some members of congress at the time
worried the guano act had ramifications
well beyond guano and fertilizer in fact
guano became totally obsolete a few
years later in the early 1900s when
a german chemist invented perhaps
the most important invention of all time
which was
synthetic fertilizer a way to actually
make fertilizer without having to get it
from like
animal waste this allowed the population
to grow to what it is today
and really change the history of
humanity but what it did is it made
guano obsolete
and yet this law that allows americans
to take over random islands and the
islands themselves
remained on the books but eventually
with time these claims for random rocks
in the pacific and caribbean
sort of just withered away and we either
withdrew the claims or people forgot
about them and they were eventually
claimed by
local countries like kitty boss or tonga
and places like haiti in the caribbean
but a few of these guano islands that we
originally claimed
remain today we still own them they're
still a part of our borders
in both the pacific and the caribbean
but the us government isn't interested
in using them for guano anymore
obviously these mostly uninhabited rocks
in the ocean
are mainly used by the us military for
landing strips
and seaports they also serve to help the
us with their ocean borders
because international law says that if
you have a piece of island
you get a big swath of ocean around it
for your exclusive economic zone meaning
the country who owns this island
has exclusive economic rights in all of
this ocean around their islands so this
greatly enhances the us's ability
to have sovereignty and control over
certain parts of the ocean in the
pacific and caribbean
but perhaps the most important result
from this guano
fest was a psychological one like we
talked about before
the u.s was expanding but it hadn't
expanded
beyond this contiguous land mass in
north america that it was taking over
rapidly in the 1800s
but soon after this law is passed
suddenly the u.s had
possessions in faraway oceans and what
happens
after this is a domino effect
suddenly if we can take over islands in
the pacific why can't we
annex hawaii or occupy cuba
or puerto rico or take over an entire
country of the philippines from spain
this law that allowed americans to claim
islands all over the world
was the first step towards real
big boy empire behavior and
it all started with the hunt for bird
[ __ ]
thanks for watching my video about bird
shed i want to tell you
about squarespace they sponsored today's
video and i'm really grateful for that
but i'm also really grateful that they
have this really cool service
on the internet where you can build a
website
using really beautiful templates and
integrations with tons of tools
like email marketing social integration
analytics everything that is just really
useful
for running an online business or
portfolio or just having a creative
presence online
squarespace just makes it easy it's like
a one-stop shop i've used squarespace
for many years long before they came to
sponsor video
and that's why i'm excited to partner
with them and promote them because i
really believe in the service
so if you are looking to either start an
online presence or revamp your online
presence
i really recommend squarespace to do
this there's a link in my description
that when you click
help support this channel but it also
gives you
an offer of 10 off any purchase you
make on squarespace so you can go get
hosting or
a domain name or whatever you need and
you'll get 10 off
if you click that link and thank you
squarespace for sponsoring this video
thank you all for watching um i am
making a lot of these u.s
expansion videos because there's so much
to cover
and so many parts of the story and
i want to piece it together in this
series so i'm going to keep doing it
and eventually we'll have like loads of
videos of how the us
grew to the shape that it is today so
keep an eye out for more of that and i
will talk to you soon
see you later